Monday the boys I grew up they said why
didn't you get that camera and take some
pictures you never get that camera so I
got him doubled up to the house got the
camera went down to the bottom of the
street where I live
saw this derelict building which the
boys always vandalized and I said jump
up there and they were individually in
between the structures and I did the
picture but they're not several months
later there was a gang war as some
people came from Islington to sort these
boys out that I grew up with because he
you know England in the fifties very
tribal seems to have gone back to that
lately and a policeman came it's a
Sunday night I wasn't there as of my
young fiance and tried to stop and and
the other guy one of the other guys
knifed him in the back and killed him
and he went to the gallows for doing
that so my career got started on a you
know a serious note of violence let me
ask you about one particular shot
because it's and I could keep seeing it
in in my eye line it's right over your
shoulder of the of the shell-shocked
Marine which tells us all about war with
not an awful lot of the horror of war
there because it's all in those another
great story really I been sleeping in
another bombed out house I took it kind
of a night away from this particular
company a Delta Company I'm sold on this
ancient war with where the fighting was
that had its most fierce and I came back
early in the morning to join them to
resume the day's fighting and I saw this
man sitting and there was a sergeant
there and I said to sergeant what's
going on here and the sergeant said Oh
him forget him you know he had total
disrespect you know anyone who quits in
the US Marines is not particularly
well-liked and so I dropped on my knees
and I did five shots of this man just
not using an automatic cover just
winding my film over and I have a job
when I look at that that strip of film
there's not one of those images that's
different from the other he never
blinked tonight it he was staring a
thousand yards beyond me and I left him
and to go into another yard
mortar dropped it in the yard smashed
the sergeant but for some miraculous
reason totally avoided hitting this
sitting Marine who was a sitting duck
when those pictures eventually came back
with me and I processed the film and I
printed all the pictures I don't think
for a second
they changed anything about the world we
live in ah well I read that and I I mean
with the greatest respect I disagree a
bit because certainly public opinion
changed did it not and it was some of
your visual images that had that effect
yeah but I could cancel out what we're
talking about here but purely I have the
evidence there was a very famous picture
of the chief of police in Saigon
shooting the man in the head that was
done in 1968 the war didn't end until
1975 so several years went by before the
war finally came to a halt and in the
end the war didn't come to a halt by a
choice of the Americans the North
Vietnamese
overwhelmed the the you know and in the
end became the glorious victors and they
smashed through those presidential gates
with their tank and you know they they
won I think in a justifiable way I mean
they sacrificed a million men to win
that war I mean you couldn't sacrifice a
million men if you were an American
president the public wouldn't have stood
for it nevertheless they lost 58,000
killed in that war the Americans in and
in the end you know the American public
couldn't stomach stomach anymore of it
really another thing that has changed
but not for the better
is is the freedom it seems you and
others had to roam to form relationships
to get under the skin in particular of
the military operation they learned the
lessons of that didn't they in a
particular ice I imagine in the next big
American conflict there were plenty in
between but one thinks of the first Gulf
War in the 90s then you got to be
embedded you were controlled you weren't
able to go where they didn't want you to
go and then wouldn't allow you to
photograph wounded soldiers I mean I've
got pictures of dead American soldiers
pictures of Americans
you know I have a picture of a soldier
that he and I were it was at dusk on
this ancient wall in hue and suddenly
between us
a Chinese hangman II and we both looked
at it and I threw myself into a
depression in the ground and he exploded
and I thought I had my leg blown off and
I was hit by a million bits of stone
luckily not the shrapnel but this thing
killed the man with me as he was a bit
goofy and a bit slow off the mark and he
as he turned around he took the whole
lot in the back of his neck and that so
he was bleeding from his nose of mouth
and ears and you know he was a goner and
um they they waited until it was dark
and then the Marines went and got his
body they they was boasted that they
would never leave their dead on the
battlefield at night so it was a an
extraordinary experience you know at the
end of the day I think the America
blamed the press for losing them that
war but they couldn't endlessly keep
pouring you know lives into that war to
prove a point I'm basically we were
really still took it about the Cold War
really but may I say you know the one
thing that you do very differently from
the the digital filmers and
photographers of today I mean we all see
it now don't worry that any event you go
to for all Matt concert whatever
children's party a large majority of the
people there are filming the event
because you're not there apparently
unless you've recorded it digitally in
all your photographs
there's engagement it's what I get is
yes you're looking through the lens for
the time being but it be it you know the
shell-shocked soldier but even a woman
at a meat counter in Harrods yeah well I
I try to be invisible which is totally
impossible of course and many people ask
me the old chestnut do you ever hide
behind the camera you can't it's only
that big what you hide behind sometimes
is the embarrassment and the orphan
issues sometimes see what's taking place
in front of you like men being massacred
in Beirut executions and starving
children you know that's when you wish
you could hide behind the
that's when you wish you were almost not
there really but they do produce these
terribly haunting powerful pictures so
there is a guilt dilemma which I'm
riddled with you know I've made an
amount of photography but a lot of it is
other people's expense